- Kyle ProTechGuy, let's see.
You good?
- [DRock] Yeah, yeah.
- You want to go here?
It's probably better, right?
Look, I understand
light now, DRock.
- [DRock] Go ahead.
- What's the most effective tool
I can use to grow my, well,
growing computer
repair business
in such a crowded marketplace?
There's tons of computer
repair companies out there
and it seem, hard to gain tract--
- [Gary] Great question.
Kyle, Google Adwords.
It will just work.
People are trying
to find that stuff.
Plus, you have to
put out content.
I see your face, you can do it.
Put out little 40 second
tips on how to repair.
I'm about to give
really good advice
that I want all of you
to pay attention to.
Come on, Kyle, come on.
Keep going, come on.
See, the thing that
people don't realize is
you want to teach
people how to fix things
without paying you for it
'cause that builds up leverage.
You give up a sale
in the beginning,
but you get all the
sales in the end.
See, that's what people
don't understand is
with Wine Library TV,
I was panning wines
and not selling those
individual wines, which
I had a lot of inventory of,
but it was bigger than that.
I was becoming
America's Wine Guy.
I became a trusted resource.
So, for Kyle in the
computer repair space,
if he puts out 30 second
videos on Facebook
and on YouTube and
10 second clips on Snapchat
and 15 second clips on Instagram
or infographics and pictures or
step-by-step tutorials about
how to fix little things that
are common mistakes.
Kyle, at this point in your
career you've seen the
same mistake 50,
100, 5,000 times.
And instead of hoping you get
one of them to pay you $100
to do something that
will take you a second
why don't you
educate the masses?
Then you start getting
authority and trust
then that becomes deal
flow for bigger business.
That's the way I'm
doing this, right?
I'm giving away so much
stuff that people charge
$89 for an e-book or
$10,000 a year for a master mind
or all the cliché shit.
My only monetization of my
information is a $19 book
once every three years.
But, all the #AskGaryVee,
all the DailyVee
I'm just trying to educate,
educate, educate.
Bring value.
And you build up
trust and guilt.
As a matter of fact,
do you know how
devastated I am that so many
of you are only going to buy
one or two books?
When I'm like, "Damn it,
why didn't you buy 4 to 6?"
It kills my thesis.
You have to be okay with
leaving a lot of
action on the table.
There's so many guys and gals
that give you a third of the
quality that I'm giving you
yet you're paying them
for a $250 courses or books.
And then, when I put out my
free book you buy one for $19
and I see that every day
but that doesn't cripple me
'cause you have to understand
doing the right thing,
in a net-net game,
is always the right thing.
I may lose the micro-battle.
Now let me get
this very clear to you,
I am losing the micro-battle.
A lot of my contemporaries
or people that are one-fourth
talented as me building
a personal brand,
life coaching, selling courses,
selling information.
You know how many people are
selling Snapchat advice
right now?
Snapchat, I saw one on
Facebook already.
The Snapchat Guide for $89
and you know how many people
are buying them? Tons.
And do you know where that guy
got all his Snapchat
advice from?
Right? And yet,
some of you bought that.
I see, I've seen it. I've actually
looked at people like
"Just got it, great,"
and literally wait a minute,
I know that name.
And looked and yet
comment on my wall too.
I know you. I know you.
You bought that for 89,
I'm giving it away for free
and then you're gonna buy
one copy of the
#AskGaryVee book.
So I'm losing the micro-battle.
I'm losing the battle
to win the war.
Get it?
I'm not trying to make
the dollars right this second,
I'm trying to build up leverage.
I'm the one showing up
on the cover of magazines,
on big TV networks,
I'm the one who's built a
$100 million agency business
on the backbone of this
because I'm the advice,
I'm the skills,
I've got the chops.
And does it hurt my feelings
that I don't win the micro-game?
Do I feel that I've given more
than others and that I deserve
to sell a million books instead
of the 150,000, 200,000,
300,000 that I'm gonna get?
Do I feel like there's
people that are selling
8, 9, $10 million in
selling you a bullshit dream
and giving you headline advice?
Do I know for a fact that
there's so many people
that are just watching my shit
repackaging it and selling
it for $200 e-books and making
more money on their community
than I am on my book?
Yes, but I don't care.
Because, first of all,
it feels nice to be on the
right side of history.
Feels nice to see the comments
from all of you that get it.
I think eventually, one day,
I'll win the
micro-battle somehow.
I haven't figured it out but
I'd rather take the war anyway.